california-based First Republic Bank got
a 30 billion dollar rescue package from
the country's biggest financial
institutions the small bank which
specialized in catering to ultra wealthy
individuals had many uninsured deposits
nervous customers began withdrawing
money rapidly after two other mid-sized
banks failed in recent days
First Republic is an interesting example
of investors I think uh anticipating a
problem where none exists
but the very anticipation in the
drawdown in their deposit base has put
the bank at some degree of risk
banking Giants JP Morgan Chase Citigroup
Bank of America and Wells Fargo agreed
to deposit five billion dollars a piece
in first Republic with other Banks
supplying smaller amounts
in a joint statement the big bank said
their rescue plans showed their
confidence in First Republic and banks
of all sizes which they added are
critical to the health and functioning
of the financial system normally a
pretty jovial group treasury secretary
Janet Yellen tried to convince Congress
and the public that there is no cause
for panic
I can reassure the members of the
committee that our banking system is
sound and that Americans can feel
confident that their deposits will be
there when they need them
this week's actions demonstrate our
Resolute commitment to ensure that our
financial system remains strong and the
depositors savings remain safe
will the private sector rescue and
public sector rhetoric be enough to
quell investors queasiness
stock market indices closed Higher One
signed the strategy may be working but
analysts say there is real fear in the
financial sector the shareholders are at
risk as was noted the the Press Republic
shares soared at the news of the of the
rescue but then they plummeted in after
hours trading and I I think we can see
that volatility continuing for a while
in other words buckle up it's going to
be a bumpy ride
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles